bench 50 points for the Philly bench
including 12 from Patrick Beverly who
joins us now and Pat you know Greg
Anthony was just mentioning this just a
few minutes ago and how your team has
really been clicking what is going on in
Philadelphia right now with that
chemistry oh man we uh first off how you
guys doing today my bad we're doing good
bro how are you CP Miss CP it's always
good to see you mama always a pleasure
great to see you yes ma'am um no we just
uh we enjoy playing with each other um
obviously we've been uh you know we got
together before the season started
probably a month month month and a half
before the season started um you know
just been around each other off the
court we're around each other um we're
able to have tough conversations that uh
you know normal teams um don't like to
have in an early season so we don't need
a lot of coaching when it comes to that
point the locker room is fun uh we want
everyone to shoot a ton of threes and uh
you know paid off today Pat Bev is
pleasure watching you guys especially
get off to this great start uh to start
the season
but you're a guy that challenges people
and I've seen in practice what can you
say about how Tyrese Maxi has grown in
this role we seen him shine when the
lights are on but in the dark when in in
practice what does he bring to your team
I mean you got to think we have a you
know we got what probably nine 10
starters you know uh collectively you
know that second unit full of Veteran
guys who've uh spent their entire career
starting so uh when you got you know
obviously the first unit get the second
unit you know I'm on the second unit so
you know I'm I'm guarding my maxi you
know I'm we we we we we got it popping
we we going at each other you know what
I'm saying white team going against Blue
so when we get on the court it's it's e
it's easy you know in practice we uh we
really give each other hell so uh I
think that's the beauty of it well you
know Pat there's so much coming into
this season having to deal with the the
drama with the James Harden scenario um
but we've been focusing a little bit
also on the leadership from from Joel
andb can you talk about that and maybe
give us a little insight to how his
leadership has manifested here this
season uh I just think he goes out there
he uh you know he goes out there and and
just does it doesn't talk a lot doesn't
you know demand a lot you know when it's
time I don't know if you guys watched
the game but I think we were in a in a
funk with OKC last game and I think he
stepped up your Center steps up and make
eight free throws in a row not you know
very poised so it's it's more of that we
see him so calm everyone is calm
obviously you know every time they do a
pick a roll they go under he's yelling
out shoot you know when you got that
from your main player your star player
Superstar player MVP it makes the game
that much easier pep have you got some
new faces on this team obviously you
being one of them but so is Nick nurse
what what kind of leadership and style
has he brought for you guys I mean he's
the great he's the best right uh you
know and I got you know when I I left
school early uh I remember meeting
meeting him in Chicago and he was the
head coach and he was trying to give me
to play for the Hour Energy you know and
15 years later you know we we we we back
playing with each other but his uh his
demeanor is so cool he's so swaggy he's
so chill you know um I mean I I don't
you know he's a players coach he
understands everything obviously he has
a system he puts his system in uh and
and everyone is reaping kind of the
benefit of it so uh it's been it's been
a pleasure all the way through Pat Bev
it's it's one thing uh to take a lot of
Threes but it's another thing to shoot
the ball the way that you all did uh
today so what can you say about was
personal yeah what can you say about you
personally four from eight from Beyond
The Arc and you as a team shooting
almost 50% yeah I knew I knew coming in
obviously you know uh you know my body
is prepared for the playoffs so you know
my my shooting percent percentage is
always starting to dirt first and kind
of Trinkle up from there uh I understand
I'm playing a team you know that I I've
been traded from uh last season and you
know uh I wouldn't say it was personal
but it was a fun one you know uh I knew
they're going to leave me open it was
just you know Nick nurse comes to me
before practice like hey I need you to
take more threes I'm like all right cool
you know I need you to take your time
and take and make more threes and uh and
I just stepped up it were wi open threes
I didn't it wasn't anything special hey
you did your thing that was a dominant
performance congratulations on the win
Pat yeah and you know AR was trying to
they hit me he hit me with the two small
last time we played him he really he
really didn't want no smoke
today